[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma grand mère était femme de ménage dans
les hauts de saint paul pour une riche
famille descendants de la famille des
bassins son grand père était un esclave
la rive par bateau comme animaux
positive bastien sa fille ma mère était
coiffeuse et moi je suis électro
chimiste
donc je suis étudiant chercheur je
travaille à l'université de la réunion
en physique énergétique
depuis tout petit elle me répétait une
chose mon enfant mon enfant laisse pas
soleil sauf d'ombrie le matin le soir
mon enfant les spas soleil sauf zombré
littéralement en français cela veut dire
ne laisse pas le soleil chauffe et au
nombril donc de la retirer de grandes
choses le travail il faut se lever tout
il faut avoir de la ténacité
l'abnégation pour réussir de grandes
choses cette pensée m'a guidé pendant
mes études et dans mon travail actuel
deuxième chose le soleil c'est grâce à
ce dicton en créole que j'ai compris
paradoxalement que le soleil était une
énergie immense
parlons de l'énergie vous savez qu l'île
de la réunion
nous n'avons pas d'énergie fossile ce
que j'entends par énergies fossiles ce
sont toutes ces énergies qui ne sont pas
renouvelables le fioul charbon pour
l'exemple mais nous avons le soleil
l'énergie solaire on peut capter grâce à
des panneaux photovoltaïques
nous avons l'énergie éolienne le vent
nous avons l'énergie des mers et nous
avons aussi des énergies qui sont
inexploités tels que la géothermie à
l'enjeu
une question toute simple pourquoi en
bientôt 2008 l'énergie solaire n'est pas
notre ressources primaires pourquoi 67 %
de l'énergie électrique qui est produite
sur l'île de la réunion provient de
l'énergie fossile à ya des réponses
alors est ce que est ce que c'est une
problématique scientifique technique
économique politique
vous savez je suis scientifique et je
vais parler de la science
la réponse est dans la question c'est
une problématique multiples à plusieurs
réponses on peut se dire bon développons
l'énergie solaire donc prenons des
panneaux photovoltaïques et mettons en
sur le toit sur nos écoles
même sur nos têtes c'est ce qu'on nous
vend actuellement l'expansion de
l'énergie solaire des panneaux
photovoltaïques
mais ce n'est qu'une petite partie de la
réponse
pourquoi
j solaire est par définition une énergie
fluctuante
en effet quand vous avez une du soleil
belle journée ensoleillée vous avez une
production électrique
le panneau photovoltaïque vous avez un
nuage cette production chute
vous avez la nuit qui arrive il n'y a
plus de production donc cette énergie
est par définition fluctuante
elle est intermittente et on peut pas la
considérer comme une énergie constante
au même titre que le fossile donc la
vraie problématique derrière des
énergies renouvelables
c'est le stockage de ces énergies alors
que faire donc
retournons au temps lontan investissons
dans la bougie de doigts alan pétrole
ça va de bef tout l'amour que j'ai
possède culture créole réunionnaise je
ne pense pas que cela puisse être
possible à l'heure actuelle consommation
et tablettes ordinateurs consoles de
jeux m'ont l'auto tune et ce n'est pas
possible
dont il faut développer des choses c'est
mon travail à moi c'est le travail de
mes collègues à l'université la réunion
notamment le stockage
parlons de ce stockage deux scénarios
possibles
prenez une famille réunionnaise
monoparentales deux enfants et des
panneaux photovoltaïques installés sur
le toit de la maison
vous avez belles journées
d'ensoleillement le panneau
photovoltaïque va vous produire de
l'électricité
imaginons que cette production est
supérieure à la demande
on stoppe le surplus de
scénario cyclone journée maussade la
production électrique est inférieure à
la demande
on utilise le cieux plus qu'on a stocké
pour produire l'électricité
c'est tout simple on appelle ça
l'énergie décentralisée
moi je pense que c'est ça l'avenir alors
le stockage vous me direz mais ça existe
pourquoi c'est pas répondu sur l'île de
la réunion
le stockage on connaît on a tous des
batteries dans nos voitures des
batteries au plomb
nous avons dans nos téléphones et
batterie lithium de nos ordinateurs
mais le pas dans le paradoxe est là on
ne peut pas stocker de l'énergie
renouvelable en utilisant un stockage
qui n'est pas renouvelable
donc il nous faut développer des
systèmes de stockage renouvelables c'est
là que l'hydrogène intervient à paris à
l'hydrogène
parlons de l'hydrogène prenez une
molécule d'où ils molécules d'eau est
composé d'un atome d'oxygène et de deux
atomes d'hydrogène sont tenus par des
lions si je mets une source électrique
des électrons avec
sur l'écologie cnic tu arrives à
dissocier ces molécules anti sociaux ces
molécules j'arrive à obtenir de
l'hydrogène ce procédé il existe depuis
très longtemps
on appelle ça le l'électrolysé de l'eau
donc à partir d'algues de zoo de l'eau
de leur robinet pour l'exemple tu
arrives pas stocker l'énergie électrique
sans passer par des matières telles que
le plomb tels que des matières incident
qui sont renouvelables
c'est magnifique le procédé inverse
aussi existent
prenez de l'hydrogène vous venez de
créer vous mettez avec de l'oxygène
vous rassemblez et vous avez une
production électrique le procédé existe
on appelle ça des piles à combustible et
ce qui est magnifique dans ces
technologies que moi je défends je crois
fortement sécu le seul réactif celle h2o
donc là on est renouvelable totalement
il a plusieurs verrous encore à lever le
premier verrou c'est le coup ça coûte
cher
économie le deuxième verrou la
durabilité
il faut que les systèmes soient de plus
en plus durable
le troisième vers où la sua t1 ça pète
comme on fait pour répondre 7 cette
problématique de ce yacht et je vous
direz vous avez chez vous des buts à des
bouteilles de butane et de propane
hautement inflammables
donc en fait suite de pédagogie pour pas
dire à cette problématique le yacht est
donc secte au logis cette technologie
elle existe et je l'espère nous
permettra demain à l'est de la réunion
l'île maurice les seychelles
toutes ces îles de l'océan indien qui
ont un fort potentiel solaire d'avoir un
coefficient de dépendance énergétique
proche de zéro bye bye le pétrole
on consomme ce que l'on produit ça c'est
mon rêve
moi j'imagine cette réunion demain on
consomme ce que l'on produit
moi j'imagine cette réunion demain qui
n'a plus besoin d'appeler quelqu'un à
15000 kilomètres pour faire venir des
tonnes et des tonnes de fioul
j'imagine une réunion demain où chaque
famille chaque quartier a sa propre
production électrique
je pense que c'est possible la
transition énergétique est possible je
citerai une sociologue florence rey nous
l a dit que l'énergie n'est pas une
simple variable qui alimentent un
système
c'est un choix c'est un choix de société
l'énergie est un choix de société
pas de société c'est vous c'est nous et
nos enfants
donc faites votre choix s'il vous plaît
je finirai par
petite anecdote vous savez dans les
années 80 à l'île de la réunion
nous étions renouvelables sans poissons
ont fonctionné totalement à l'énergie
hydroélectrique sur l'île de la réunion
avant les années 80 on était 300 milles
on n'avait pas ce mode de vie que nous
avons actuellement
mais ce qui est marrant là dedans quand
on écoute le discours global qui nous
disait bien sûr il faut aller vers de
nouvelles technologies
dirigeant les grandes consciences des
scientifiques
le futur sera renouvelable ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que nous notre passé et
est renouvelable et en tant que
réunionnais en tant qu'île loi en tant
que personnes n'ayant pas de ressources
fossiles
le futur notre futur sera notre passé
sera le retour à nos valeurs anciennes
au le réunionnais ses valeurs créole de
consommation raisonnée de consommation
décentralisée moi je trouve ça
magnifique pour finir c'était moi j'aime
le maloya mal grâce à la musique
traditionnelle de l'île de la réunion
j'adore cette ce style j'aime aussi la
science comme vous avez pu le comprendre
et avec mes amis on invente on inventer
un maloya renouvelables le maloya
l'énergie renouvelable
ça fait comme ça au soleil lippé clerity
baballe est salie cléry quand lives
arrive à t1 à rodez manière pour
transforme ali merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]